[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome we want a present for forever we
want a future we can count on in a past
that never dies Todd told us get your
life together call it on it's like a TA
just don't look him in the eyes
why oh if he's lying so quick so far see
time looks shorter on a G Cal but long
in that seminar so when you want some
more time knowing how to ask is hard and
time was shutting to Thompson hold on
let me get this straight you won you
want to be on all the college councils P
liaison and debate you want three a.m.
nights and three p.m. class you want a
Wenzel in ten minutes but you also
stretch the cash you need your technical
by a week ago and your PDF won't do you
want to grab a meal with everyone I mean
I mean not tomorrow but soon
you don't want to lose your friends you
don't want to lose you at school but you
want to look your family in the eye and
say I did this for you the sunset is
bittersweet because the night brings all
our fears but we got all the acid of
time and still shine bright as these
College earrings so listen be present
for all these students and speakers
celebrates your classmates and pay
homage to all your teachers see tom has
to take some things but leaves us
something better than the things we
really take from you other things that
last
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone
thank you for coming from nearby and as
far away as Japan Argentina and even TD
[Applause]
singers Congrats on surviving Myrtle and
his senior week my name is Tommy
Rosencrantz and I'm secretary of the
class of 2017 and my name is Mimi Pham
and I'm the treasurer of the class of
2017 as your class officers we are
beyond excited to kick off class day
celebrations tomorrow we will leave Yale
with the wealth of experiences in our
backpacks we will look back on our
accomplishments that have taken place
under lamplight and sterling in the
laboratory and on the playing field
perhaps for some with the chalice in
hand at Morrie's to each their own but
in the years ahead
it is the experiences and the sage
wisdom we have gained more so than the
achievements that we will recall so
fondly it has been the meaningful
relationships we have forged with each
other that have truly transformed us and
have driven us to become better versions
of ourselves today we will reflect on
all of these experiences we'll hear a
speaker will have listened to our
classmates reflections through speech
song and poetry we will celebrate our
cosmic successes we will look back on
our own and imagine our future ones but
let's not forget some of the most
important people in our lives we would
also like to take a moment to thank our
families friends professors and mentors
without your guidance and invested in us
we would not be who we are today it is
because you saw our potential and
invested in us that we will graduate
tomorrow thank you for always being our
support systems
in closing we hope that the community
that we celebrate today continues to
grow and that we continue to bask in the
reflected glory here's to our
experiences past present and future
welcome to class
hello class of 2017
my name is Larry Milstein and I'm Joanna
and oh and Azure and as your class take
cochairs we are so excited to introduce
this year's class day speaker Theo
Epstein president of baseball operations
for the Chicago Cubs and a member of the
Yale College class of 1995
perhaps best known as the leader who
defied all odds to break two of the most
famous curses a major league baseball
first in 2004 when you let the Boston
Red Sox for their first World Series
championship in 86 years breaking the
curse of the Bambino and second just
last fall when the Cubs broke the curse
of the Billy Goat and won the World
Series for the first time in 106 years
[Music]
and if we may add only weeks after
Epstein accepted our invitation this
fall to speak at this year's class day
the Yale football team upset harbor to
win in the game wait there's more
there's more this past week the Yale
baseball team snatched the Ivy League
championships for the first time since
1994
was this yet another broken curse that
could be attributed to the magic of
epstein the world may never know
off-the-field
Epstein has had its fair share of home
runs over the past twelve months he was
named the world's greatest leader by
Fortune magazine helped raise millions
of dollars with his brother for his
foundation for disadvantaged youth and
in January President Obama described him
as one of the greatest general managers
of all time but more maybe in
indignities however Epstein also hit it
out of the park here at Yale not only
was he a member of the best residential
college of all of you Jonathan
[Applause]
he was also the sports editor for the
Yale Daily News another role that
certainly require some heavy hitting
after graduating with a degree in
American Studies after the entire lease
tried to prove himself in the world of
sports he worked his way up from the
bottom first interning with the
Baltimore Orioles that is spending five
years at the San Diego Padres and in
2002 achieving his dream when he was
named youngest general manager in the
history of the MLB by the Boston Red Sox
at the age of 28 and and for all you
future lawyers in the audience
leptin also earned his law degree from
the University of San Diego in 2000 all
while balancing a full-time career but
perhaps the most exciting part of having
Epstein here today is that as his story
offers us a lesson that goes far beyond
sports and is particularly compelling as
we prepare to graduating he is someone
who had the courage to dream big pursue
his passion and continue to give back to
others please give a warm welcome home
to miserabile a steam
thank you
looks like I'm lucky in there some Cubs
fans here today let's just get that
important stuff out of the way right now
how many Cub fans are here serious and
how many Red Sox fans are here and last
how many Yankee fans are here
I see Yankee fans the exits are just
around back right out Phelps gate and
keep walking presidents Ave heads of
College College Dean's members of the
faculty and staff good afternoon members
of the class council class state chairs
go in and Larry class secretary Tommy
class treasurer and Mimi in the entire
Yale class of 2017 greetings and
congratulations
I'm honored to be with you here today to
help celebrate and I'd like to thank
Joanna and Larry for inviting me on
behalf of the whole class and for that
to kind introduction thank you your
class has been witnessed to in a
participant in a period of historic
change here Yale the inauguration of a
new president the creation of two new
residential colleges the renaming of a
third and perhaps most savory of all the
introduction of Hanoi fried kpr at
university dining and I would like to
recognize some of the members of your
class who had special accomplishments
this year as Joanna and Larry mentioned
be a baseball team for just this week
cleaning the Ivy League and returning to
the NCAA tournament for the first time
since 1994 congratulations guys also
done the women's women's winning the
IV's for the first time in 20 years
that's because he mentioned the elf
football team first time in ten years
meeting Harvard way to go to Mohawk and
last but not least Saybrook for just ah
hi watch the game this year that's just
an unprecedented commitment to the
Saybrook strip that was saw I think I
remember back in my day we had kept her
underwear on and didn't get mauled off
by Harvard police but thank you thank
you for taking into the next level that
is what we call progress I'd also like
to thank some others who are here today
it's important first of all my family
including my father Leslie class of 60
and my sister Anja class of 92
I know despite your great faith in me
that you're a little surprised that I'm
the one up here today next some of my
friends and classmates at Yale who are
here today with whom I discovered the
great institutions of higher learning
Tony's place and Rudy's
and wasted more than our share of brain
cells in pursuit of the knowledge hidden
there I know you are shocked as I am
about this honor here today and finally
a nod to my professors especially my
terrific graduate student teaching
assistants thank you all for your
invaluable tutelage I know you were
somewhat amused that I made it to my own
class day so you've got to be downright
horrified that I'm the one up here today
I do remember my years at Yale very
fondly and as you'll find out
a young degree is something that stays
with you the rest of your life back in
2002 when at 28 years old I stumbled
into becoming general manager of the Red
Sox days after I was hired my boss fired
Luke Ino was visiting an old baseball
colleague of his president george w bush
class of 68 in the White House President
Bush asked what are you doing
naming a 28 year old as general manager
because that's as far too young that's
an absurd risk lukina replied no no mr.
president you don't understand he's a
Yale man to which the president replied
strike two
like the former president I didn't do
anything to series of my career
I just worked in baseball yes America's
national pastime but also largely just a
part of the bread and circuses of
society entertaining and distracting us
while up there was like my twin brother
Paul who's here today a social worker do
the real work of holding our communities
together
but there are certainly times when
baseball is much more than bread and
circus times when baseball resonates
deeply and meaning meaningfully for many
many people and times when a game that
is built around overcoming failure can
teach us all a few important lessons so
class of 2017
if you don't indulge me I'm going to
tell just one baseball story it's a bit
long but you'll like the ending and
unless you're from Cleveland in which
case I'm deeply sorry the story is about
a very important game game seven last
year's World Series but as little to do
with the actual outcome of the game for
those who don't follow baseball a little
quick background I worked with the
Chicago Cubs a team with the following
so loyal and adoring in history so
forlorn
that we were known nationwide as the
lovable losers as a blast fall the Cubs
in nomina World Series since 1908 think
about that 1908
that's the Teddy Roosevelt
administration the Ottoman Empire was
still around and kick
that's two world wars ago way I actually
haven't checked the news since breakfast
just give me one second
good news it's still just two world wars
I got all in all it was a 108 year
drought the longest in the history of
professional sports as the late comes
broadcasting legend Jackie rodowskys to
say anybody can have a bad century I
joined the Cubs in 2011 I'm inordinate
and uncomfortable amount of media
attention the Chicago sun-times I
remember we had a full page front page
photo shop of me walking on water across
Lake Michigan
as if by showing up I was going to
miraculously turn around the team's
fortunes imagine their disappointment
then when one year at 101 101 losses
later I'm sorry Matt to their
disappointment then when I announced
meeting the long-term rebuilding plan
built around acquiring young players
built around winning five years down the
line so one season in 101 losses later
the same paper ran the identical photo
of me but this time the only thing about
the water was the tip of my nose one day
in the early years with the Cubs after
particularly humiliating double-digit
loss at home at Wrigley I was walking
home amongst the fans in a bit of a foul
mood and I remember had my head down
trying not to get recognized a very
charming elderly woman recognized me she
spotted me and he came over to ask a
question she said I appreciate what
you're trying to do young man I really
do I understand why you bringing in so
many young players but tell me exactly
when are you planning on winning the
World Series I'm not sure how much time
I have left
so I was a little taken aback and all I
could think of to say as I put my head
back down to walk away was men I hope
you taking vitamins that was five years
ago but if happened today and I say
ma'am I hope you don't have any
pre-existing conditions
so after three years of arduous
rebuilding we had a nucleus of young
players of because we believe in who are
ready to break into the majors together
many of these players are 21 22 years
old your peers your generation typically
it takes young players years to invest a
life in the big leagues and to start
planning up to their capabilities most
of the blame of this rests on these
ridiculous old baseball norms that say
young players have to be seen and not
heard that young players must follow and
not me
that young players must adhere to the
established codes from the dress code
that requires them to wear suits and
ties to the CODIS as major league
players can't get too excited or look
like they're having too much fun out
there on the field thankfully we hired a
manager in Joe Madden who agreed it was
time to turn these conventions on their
heads we asked our young players to be
themselves to show their personalities
to have fun to be daring to be bold the
dress code was came from suit and tie -
if you think you look hot wearing
unburdened and empowered our young team
flourish class season winning 103 games
and most of all baseball in reaching our
first World Series since 1945 after
fighting back in the three games and one
deficit Cleveland Indians we face a
decisive Game seven in Cleveland
I watched Game seven from the stands
with my colleagues my wife Marie and my
oldest son Jack who was then 8 years old
Jack a big baseball fan and the math
whiz of the family kept me updated on
the cub Win Probability throughout the
course of the game
so as we enjoyed a two-run lead after
five innings he Tammy on the leg Dan we
have a 67 percent chance of winning the
World Series I know buddy it's going
well but remember it's baseball and lots
of things could happen it's all anything
to say so later we had a three-run lead
with just four outs to go in the game
nobody on base in the bottom of the
Indians order coming to the plate tens
of millions of Cubs fans nationwide
counting down the hounds put their arms
around loved ones or call them to keep
them close for the big moment ahead Jack
put his arm around me dad we have a 97%
chance away to the World Series
I know buddy I know it's so great but
one matter at a time
we still need four more outs we don't
want to look too far ahead but that
first time in a hundred eight years just
then out of nowhere as storm clouds
moved into the area an infield single a
double an airing fastball a fatal swing
in a possible home run in a tie game
Indians fans erupted rocking the stadium
on his foundational year splittings
year's Cubs fans and I slumped in our
seats heads and hands just that I felt
another top of my leg dad we definitely
have less than a 50% chance of winning
the World Series luck I couldn't think
of anything wants to say so I just
thought up in my seat starik stowing me
out of the field put one arm around my
son and with the other I chopped his
hand tap his leg is reassuringly as I
could minutes later the skies opened up
and rain Malta the action it was just
enough of a pause to ponder the
magnitude of the situation extra innings
in Game seven of the World Series an
entire season down to this one moment a
five-year plan down to this one moment
and for Cub fans 108 years of patience
and under whited love down to Vaughn
Bowman still in a bit of a daze that
come through our Clubhouse towards the
meeting about the weather turning a
corner I saw through the window of the
waiting room door the backs of our
players jerseys blue jerseys shoulder to
shoulder pack tiny all 25 guys leads
into a space design for about half that
many it was an unusual sight we hardly
ever had meetings never during a game
ing closer to the door I saw roll this
happen the pit
giving up the game-tying homerun in
tears I lingered just long enough to
hear a few sentences we would not even
be here without you kept your David Ross
has said as he embraced captain we're
going to win this for you we're going to
win this for each other
outfielder Jason Heyward walked to the
middle of the room we are the best team
in baseball he said we cleaned on each
other all year we still got this this is
only going to make it sweeter and then
first may seem an aneurysm nobody can
take this away from us we have each
other
Kyle schwarber stood up with a baton
Sam's we win this right here said I
turned away a big smile on my face and
headed to that weather being ten minutes
later the rain cleared
schwarber let off with a single Zobrist
doubled this past three the third
baseman and we took the lead in the
bottom of the 10th the tying run on base
is the winning run on the play at 12:47
a.m.
Chris Brian filmed a slow roller with a
gigantic smile on his face and through
the wisdom of the final out becomes one
of the World Series
comedy improv on over my mind and I
embrace and celebration equal parts
ecstasy in relief I noticed that's now a
game
the young mathematician was shocked it
overjoyed that we had for one to beat
the odds
later that morning back in bring the
team bus past the cemetery on the ride
from O'Hare driven back in Chicago we
saw countless cops hats and pennants
already great plug me over tombstones
for family members who did not quite
living to see the moment the next day
five million triumphant Chicagoans for
every corner of the immense city
gathered downtown for a big victory
parade the seed of blue was a beautiful
sight Chicago fractious and in danger II
was united in the aftermath of the
championship after all the champagne a
dried we finally got a good night's
sleep
I found myself returning to one simple
question what did I tell Jack his
younger brother drew about this historic
achievement what was it exactly that I
wanted them to hold on to I thought
immediately of the players meeting
during the rain delay and how connected
they were with each other how invested
they were in each others face how they
turned each other's tears into
determination during rain delays players
typically coming on the field head to
throwing Walker's sit there by
themselves they change the winters ease
they check their phones they think about
what song writing wrong during the game
they become engrossed
little worlds that would have been
disastrous for our team during Game
seven 25 players sitting alone in the
lockers lamenting the bat breaks
assigning blame wallowing wondering
instead they have the instinct to come
together actually it was not an instinct
it was a choice one day I will tell
dagger true that some players some of us
go through our careers with their heads
down focused on our craft our tasks
keeping to ourselves worrying about our
numbers or our grade pursuing the next
objective goal
building our resumes projecting our
individual interest other players and
others amongst us go through our careers
with their heads up as a real part of
the team alert and aware of others
embracing difference employing empathy
genuinely connecting putting collective
interests ahead of our own it is a
choice the former approach keeping her
head down seems safer and more efficient
and I guess sometimes it is the latter
connecting keeping our heads up allows
us to lead and every now and then to be
part of something much greater than
ourselves and therefore to truly triumph
I know I will tell them that try it both
ways and I'll tell tack Andrew that we
all have our rain-delay moments there
will be times when everything you've
been wanting everything you have worked
for everything you've earned everything
you feel you deserve is snatched away in
what seems like a personal and unfair
blow this I will tell them
it's called life but when these moments
happen and they will will you be alone
after locker with your head down
lamenting giving up blame or will you be
shoulder to shoulder with your teammates
connected with your heads up giving and
receiving
the former and I will tell them not to
wait until the rain comes to make this
choice because that would be too late
we weren't winners at 19 Cleveland guess
he ended up one more run than the
Indians it's over smaller than four
inches farther off the line that double
would have been double play we would
have lost the game that was randomness
like much of life it was arbitrary we
were winners that night in Cleveland
because when things went really really
wrong and then when the rains came
our players already knew each other so
well that they could come together they
already trusted each other so much that
they could open up and be vulnerable and
they've already we're so connected that
they could lend one another up we had
already won that's why I had that smile
on my face as I walked away from the
waiting room door and later learned that
the players only being ed involved by
Hayward a 27 year old suffering through
a terrible offensive disease and by far
the worst of his career most players who
are having seasons that rough detached
themselves from the team either head to
the disabled list or at the periphery of
the clubhouse isolated themselves but
Hayward skated the center of everything
he never stopped being invested in his
teammates he opened up to them about
struggles he bought them sweets on the
road for gatherings the first to speak
in the meetings Ross 38 year old backup
captured in his final season we made a
career out of getting a wonderful
teammate and by the way is now in the
finals of Dancing with the Stars
you thought you were on record here Ross
even always reaching out to friends the
loneliest players always organizing team
dinners always bringing down the
barriers that sometimes arrive between
players of different backgrounds in the
clubhouse the last to speak of the media
was Rizzo the young team leader who all
season long was reminding his teammates
that they were going to make history
together they're going to have a parade
and then be playing in eternity forever
Anthony a survivor of pediatric cancer
just celebrated the World Series by
making a three and a half million dollar
gift to Chicago's lurie Children's
Hospital
shorebird go to the back his hands and
raised out the meeting into the batter's
box at torn to ligaments in his knee in
the third game of the season 12 to 15
month injury rather than disappearing to
a rehab facility Warburg is 23 years old
stay connected with the team gangs rehab
work done early in the morning so
teammates didn't have to see him in that
state and then functioning as an expert
coach for his teammates the rest of the
day kept telling his teammates he was
going to find a way to be there for them
find a way to help them win shocking the
doctors and everyone else
Farber returned in just six months
writing time for the World Series he hit
400 over 400 in the World Series
including that single to start the
deciding rally in Game seven so early in
my career I used to think of players as
assets statistics on spread I could use
to project future performance and
measure precisely how much they were
getting impact our team on the field I
used to think of teams as portfolios
diversify flagons of player assets paint
reproduce up to their projections to
ensure the organization success my head
had been down that narrow approach
worked for a while but it certainly has
its limits I grew and my team building
philosophy grew as well the truth as our
team proved in Cleveland is that a
player's character matters the heart
beat matters fears and aspirations
matter the players impact on others
matters the tone he sets matters the
willingness to connect battles breaking
down cliques and overcoming stereotypes
my Clubhouse matters who you are how you
move among others that all matters the
youngest team in World Series history
six starters under the age of 25 they
helped me get my head up
that is why at the important moments in
their lives I'm going to keep telling my
sons about the 2016 Cubs and that ready
delay and I'll remind them when they are
graduating college for starting a new
job heading off to grad school or
beginning a new life somewhere foreign
that they have a choice so class of 2017
as someone who has already been molested
by members of your generation I am
thankful and really in awe of what you
all can accomplish when given the space
to be free to let their personalities
out
it's a figured out I'm truly inspired by
the traits that distinguish your
generation your diversity your boldness
your optimism your tolerance your
treatment of others based on substance
rather than on the labels that you see
due to bias I'm so excited see what lies
ahead for you all while there will
undoubtedly be times here and there when
you have to suck it up follow the code
put on that suit in time I heard you to
remember that if you think you look hot
wear
and please remember that even though so
much can be quantified these days the
most important things cannot be and
finally when things go really really
wrong and then when it rains on top of
everything else fingers crossed for
tomorrow I ask you to choose to keep
your heads up and come together to
connect and to rally around one another
especially those who need the most is
lightning to uplift you all thank you
and congratulations
I thought enough to hacker me didn't
keep up to take a hound like wait a
second
we'll look for some alright so some of
our walked up on stage here a friend of
mine said it one of you one of you
brought these leis to my wife and for me
who is that person
thank you so much what's up with the
rest of you I mean I know it's a vacuum
but I'm leaving in no
come on thank you
you know this is really dangerous I've
got nothing left to say pretty much the
rest of this uh commencement I got this
microphone my script says to improvise a
little bit actually says that provides a
few lines so dangerous moment what's
going to happen so I graduated on my PhD
here in 1995 I didn't notice until I
looked at the program that mr. Epstein I
hold him feel back of the day that we
graduated in the same year tomorrow
you're going to be on campus and
hopefully the skies will be well not
when raining and you might wonder like I
wondered then no the beautiful fanfare
the flags the pageantry and I'm not as
fair Co Commission and I wondered my
goodness what are they celebrating a
king are they is our future president in
the audience and I thought could be
think about that what I didn't know is
that there be a future creator crafter
organizer of World Series championships
teams yellows whole surprises as it
turns out the question I have you is
what are you going to do no pressure at
home now I know this day is about you
and then rightly so but I am I am
heading off to Northwestern it's a city
near Chicago
and you know he and I go back a long way
they said Connecticut Hall action where
we met um for walking in here and you
know so I got a business card at
Northwestern John Collinwood was 90 you
and you know tickets
[Applause]
always fun
[Applause]
okay enough about these years I have
some business I need to conduct with you
but first I want to ask following
students to come up to the seats in the
front row along here
Alexandra likes far little grammar
polish come on down Andrew broad of
Berkeley College Abigail Paula elder of
Calhoun College Devon flowers appear
some powers
[Music]
John made of more scholars
Richard Thomas McCoy of Branford College
[Applause]
[Music]
Katherine Miller of Pierson powers James
Brandon of Moore's College
[Applause]
[Music]
and Rousseau of Berkeley College Francis
VT of Pearson college
Emily Marie Switzer Ezra Stiles college
[Applause]
Abdul Razak Zakaria
[Applause]
[Music]
christena Qi Shang of Sabre collars
[Applause]
[Music]
seniors we need to do a little dress
rehearsal for tomorrow at commencement
is going to be a point when I stand up
here in front of president Salome and
present you to him so that you can
receive your degrees listen carefully
please the last two sentences of my
request the president Sall they are
going to be and I quote they have been
recommended by the Faculty of Yale
College and approved by the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees when you
hear those last two words that I last
phrase confer upon them these degrees I
want to hear you loud and clear your
graduating for goodness sakes so we're
going to do this once don't mess it up
they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
[Applause]
you Yalies are fast learners well done
Tom Beck will present awards for
athletics prizes would ask that
Catherine Miller Frances speed
James randon and John Hayden please come
up to the stage
[Applause]
it is my honor to award to the senior
woman and male whose excellence in
athletics and in their lives at Yale
best represent the ideals of
sportsmanship in the Yale tradition the
Nelly Elliott award is given to the
senior woman and the William Mallory to
the senior male as you can see we have
two of each I will start with catherine
miller the captain of the women's
fencing team and guided the 2016 team to
a 12th place finish in the NCAA
championship catherine earned
all-american and all-ivy honors in 2015
she took a leave of absence to train
with a Brazilian national team earning a
spot that Catherine competed for Brazil
in the 2016 Olympic Games in Rio
[Music]
[Music]
Francis Meade is one of the most
decorated distance runner in Yale
history she is a native of Brazil excuse
me
Australia sorry Francis that confused
with Catherine it has earned
all-american and all ID honors during
her yield career Francis is the Ivy
League record holder in the thousand
meters the Yale record holder in the
mono 1500 meters 1000 meters and she
also captained the cross-country team to
the NCAA Championship congratulations
the Mallory Awards
James randon
James is the first runner in the hundred
plus year history of Yale track and
field to break the four-minute mile
he joined this world-class group of
runners with an astonishing time of
three minutes fifty eight point eight
seconds James is the first team
all-american a four-time track and field
IV champion and in 2016 he won the Ivy
League cross country championship he's a
history major Morris College James will
continue his running career and attempt
to make the United States Olympic team
for the 2020 Olympic Games in Tokyo
John Hayden captain an MVP of the Yale
hockey team he was a three-time first
name all IV and ECAC elite performer
John helped the Bulldogs the two Ivy
championships and two trips to the
national championship tournament he is
seventh in the nation in scoring this
year it immediately upon completing his
Yale academic assignments he joined the
Chicago Blackhawks of the National
Hockey League where he played
immediately scoring his first goal in
his second game and offering additional
support to a team who made it to the
playoffs of the National Hockey League
congratulations Johnny
[Applause]
[Applause]
the NA Konishi prize is awarded to two
graduating seniors who while maintaining
high academic achievement have provided
exemplary leadership in enhancing race
or ethnic relations at Yale College
this year's prizes are awarded to
Alexandra Barlow of Branford College
[Applause]
and Abu Rosario
[Applause]
[Music]
an african-american studies major and
Mellon Mays research fellow graduating
with distinction
les Barlow has focused her scholarship
on issues of land usage cooperative
economies and reparations in the
American South she is described as a
fierce truth teller who illuminates the
challenges affecting her communities
rooting them in history and context in
order to promote a deeper understanding
of them her peers say of her Lex never
fights for just one issue her moral
imagination operates with the knowledge
that issues of race class gender
sexuality etc are all interconnected
Lex has also worked tirelessly to build
bridges among organizations and
individuals pushing relentlessly for a
more equitable and just campus and world
through her activism serving as past
president and social justice chair for
the Black Student Alliance at Yale a
communication and consent educator and
an organizer for the group FRA
fossil-free Yale she brings womanist
feminists anti-racist work to the fore
with academic rigor and a deep integrity
and she has by example taught her peers
faculty and administrators about
inclusive leadership to recognize all
she has accomplished in the service of
race and ethnic relations Yale College
is honored to bestow the nakanishi Prize
upon Alexandra Marlowe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Abdul Razak Zakaria who graduates with
distinction has worked to improve Yale's
racial and ethnic relations to his
academic work both within his sociology
major and in the education Studies
Program a recipient of a melon maize
research fellowship he has explored the
topic of respectability politics in
mentorship organizations for black male
teenagers in New Haven in the first of
his two senior essays in his second he
examines multiculturalism and racial
representations in children's literature
Abdul has devoted himself equally to
community engagement mentoring youth of
color as a member of Yale's LAT men's
union guiding and welcoming peers as a
cultural connections counselor and
caring for first-year students as a
freshman counselor for Timothy white
college
as a member of the undergraduate
first-generation low-income partnership
duel has played vital roles as
recruitment coordinator for the office
of Undergraduate Admissions the New
Haven outreach coordinator for Timothy
Dwight college and undergraduate
representative to the Yale president's
Task Force on diversity and inclusion to
recognize all he had accomplished in the
service of race and ethnic relations the
AL college is honored to the so the
nominee she prize upon uh Barack Razak
Sicario
[Applause]
[Music]
the James Andrew Haas prize is awarded
annually to that member of the senior
class in Yale College whose breadth of
intellectual achievement strength of
character and fundamental humanity shall
be adjudged by the faculty to provide
leadership for his or her fellow
students inspiring in them a love of
learning and concern for others this
year the Haas Prize is awarded to Javon
flowers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Jevon JT flowers graduates with
distinction in the political science
major and with a record that reflects
his intellectual curiosity his deep
sense of justice and his commitment to
others in and beyond Yale College JT has
participated in the wide array of
extracurricular activities ranging from
the black men's union to word and on on
campus full of a performance group from
his work on the financial aid task force
to his serving as both a counsellor for
cultural connections and appeared the
Azon for the afro-american cultural
center his passion for justice and his
dedication to his fellow students are
encapsulated in his role as founder and
president of a lake even a nonprofit
that he established as a means to
advocate for the academic and
professional success of low-income
students a winner of numerous awards and
prizes he was recently granted a gordon
grand public service fellowship to
support his proposal to work next year
with local governments in his home city
of Portland Oregon for all that he has
done and an anticipation of all he will
do Yale College is proud to bestow the
James Andrew Haas Memorial Prize for
2017 on ginger bond JT flowers
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is nominee and I'm a
graduating senior in wars when I first
arrived at Yale I wanted to distance
myself from the Indian stereotypes but
it followed me all through high school
students bound for med or law school
immigrant I wanted to be someone
different to become the outgoing
socialite that I never was in high
school to be an American college girl it
turns out that my Indian heritage was a
part of me that I couldn't trade in from
the movie like college experience
because I missed my old life I wanted to
bring a piece of my home to you and for
me that home was Bertha Natyam a 3,000
year old form of Indian classical dance
that I learned growing up in Portland
Oregon when I first started I remember
struggling with a low Padma and cotton
kombucha two very intricate hand
gestures in bars and opium but as I
became more skilled I began to
appreciate the importance of the
expression rhythm and footsteps that
this dance form demands the stamping of
my feet against the floor to the beat of
the drum and the melody of the flute it
was this dancing that brought me into a
rich and diverse community here at Yale
poised to change the world it all
started in an engineering class
differential equations one day an
african-american woman that I sat next
to ask me what Indian language I spoke I
answered shyly fellows ooh no param and
Giri she casually respondent an
african-american from Boston just
introduced herself to me
at that moment any stereotypes that I
had were shattered
to my surprise injury had also been
learning Indian classical dance for
several years in Boston our shared
interest in this ancient form of art
eventually developed into a friendship
together we co-founded color yields
Indian classical dance group now after
three years performing with Yale kala
nothing has made me happier I'm looking
around the Moors college dance studio
and seeing everyone from my best friend
it's enough from India to our newest
freshman members from California and
Texas as we work together to unify the
fallen the Sanskrit word for coordinated
be I believe the strength of our column
shows the power of our forest bond our
synchrony is flawless with our hands
rising on the same count perfected to
the millisecond there were times though
when we were offbeat when we stumbled on
the fallen we disagree over how
traditional our group should be some
wanted to dance more modern sounding
songs influenced by Western culture
while I and a few others only wanted to
dance to Indian classical music
preserving its established form but why
does it have to be one or the other we
dance to the cadence of a rhythm unique
to our Yale experience for celebratory
performances we dance to upbeat songs
and we stay true to the pure classical
form for ceremonial events
dancing to the solemn was about finding
our unified heartbeat about getting back
together when we were off thee what we
came to represent was the intellectual
spiritual and cultural diversity here at
Yale
even though we all have our differences
in nationality in life science in
convictions we all share in one
synchronized song in one common purpose
that unites us as the ELL students as
members of the class of 2017 growing up
in a globalized 21st century we aren't
afraid to ask the questions that matter
just as my dance group tried to
reconcile how to respect tradition while
being aware of the changing times we we
as a student community asked does the
past still have a place in today's
society these are the questions that
have come to distinguish our class and
time at Yale from the storm that
rocketed last year that led to open
discussion and the nationwide coverage
of our campuses March of resilience our
efforts to seek answers to these
difficult questions have led to tangible
changes in college naming and how we
address the hierarchy of our university
leaders and so much more to come this
unified heartbeat problem in all of us
will stay with us as we leave from Yale
and continue our work bringing about
change thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the War Memorial High scholarship prize
for the senior majoring in humanities
who ranks highest in scholarship is
awarded this year to Abigail
Paula elder of Calhoun College
[Applause]
Abbey elder Abbey elder has
distinguished herself at Yale as both a
student and musician elected to Phi Beta
Kappa in her senior year she graduates
summa [ __ ] laude with distinction in her
major
there we go that's close enough she
graduates the distinction of her major
Near Eastern languages and civilizations
having earned forty point five course
credits with no grade lower than a - and
with 36 grades of straight day
abby's coursework Abbey's course was
drawn on three foreign spoken languages
Hebrew Spanish and Arabic but she also
communicates eloquently in the universal
language of music to reveal the
performance in a range of groups and
programs domestically and abroad a
former principal violas in the Yale
Symphony Orchestra and an ongoing
participant in the Perlman music program
a Diaz combined her kids as a musician
with her work as a scholar putting both
in the service of bringing Arab and
Jewish children together through music
programs in Israel in recognition of her
exemplary achievements as a student and
musician Yale College is proud to award
the War Memorial High scholarship prize
this year to Abigail
Paula elder
[Music]
the Arthur explaining Tammy prize which
honors the memory of the man who served
as president of Yale for 1999 to 1921 is
awarded annually to the senior Neil
College majoring in the social sciences
who ranks highest in scholarship this
year that Hadley prizes to be awarded to
Andrew broad of Berkeley College Andrew
[Music]
elected to Phi Beta Kappa in his senior
year Andrew brought graduates summa [ __ ]
laude with distinction in his economics
and mathematics major having her in 43
grades of a
what the heck impressive you've been
doing
his professors in writing of Andrews
beef repeatedly and eloquently of his
focus and work ethic crediting both for
the excellence of his scholarship andrew
has brought the same level commitment
and excellence through a range of
activities on campus as a founding
member of Hamid a student group that
focuses on providing financial education
and practical experience andrew has been
active in creating a student-run
investment fund student-run consulting
projects and a summer fellowship in
Israel he has also been a committed
member of Yale's music community serving
since his freshman year as a clarinetist
of both the eyo concert band and the
Berklee College orchestras in
recognition of his exceptional record
Yale College proudly confers the arthur
climbing heavy high scholarship prize
this year upon andrew
[Applause]
[Music]
the Russell Henry Chittenden prize is
awarded annually for the senior majoring
in the Natural Sciences or in
mathematics who ranks highest in
scholarship this year's prize is awarded
to a diverse Oh
[Applause]
collective the Phi Beta Kappa in her
junior year and Abruzzo graduates summa
[ __ ] laude with distinction in both our
four majors applied mathematics and
economics she has earned grades of a and
every one of her 39 and a half credits
added is the recipient of numerous
awards among them the Yale Science
Engineering Association Award for
outstanding academic achievement the
Heinz wrexham prize for the best senior
essay in the field of the social
sciences and the Bishop Berkeley prize
given by Berkeley College the student
who best discovered intellectual
potentialities of the University and has
balanced her academic accomplishments
with others in the Yale and New Haven
community as a regular contributor and
Co editor-in-chief of the Yale globalist
Anna has written eloquently of women's
issues around the world focusing on
health and education and here in New
Haven
she has mentored low-income high school
students serving as a valued guide to
them as they prepare for college in
recognition of her commitment to
academic excellence Yale College proudly
Awards the Russell Henry Chittenden
prize
[Applause]
the Lewis enterprises for excellence in
the Performing and creative arts our
word to to outstanding seniors Emily
Switzer Ezra Stiles college and
Christina Janko saber College
Italy slit servile Ennis is one of the
most accomplished musicians ever to
attend do college a superb embodiment of
the scholar musician
Emily plays with unerring technique
elegant musicianship and calm competence
she served as a concert master of the
Yale Symphony Orchestra and was the
winner of this year's William wait
Concerto Competition in which he
delivered his son performance of the
Shostakovich violin concerto number one
an English major who graduates [ __ ] laude
with distinction she has been recognized
both within and outside Yale twice
receiving a coveted fellowship to the
Music Academy of the West Festival and
chosen as a 2017 New York Philharmonic
global Academy Fellow in January she
performed the New York Philharmonic
Orchestra this summer she'll be a fellow
of the tangle of Music Festival and then
we'll return to Yale to continue her
studies as a master's student in the
School of Music for her exceptional
talent and building brilliant
musicianship Yale College is delighted
to award the Lewis sublet Clark prize
for excellence in the Performing Arts to
Emily Switzer
verzino jiang an architecture made with
graduating with distinction is a
visionary designer whose ketika proach
two structures is matched by passionate
engagement with humanitarian concerns
per scene is the co-founder and director
of a nonprofit organization that has
already completed his first project
working in collaboration with refugees
at the kuma refugee camp in Northwest
Kenya Cristina has built a learning
center inside the camp with funds she
raised in the United Nations refugee
agency she is now in the process of
staging an international competition to
design a public marketplace for three
refugee camps in Jordan Germany and
Kenya that will not only benefit the
people who live there but also
illuminate the potential of design to
reimagine refugee settlements in crisis
her panel of jurors includes UN
ambassadors world bank directors and
distinguished architects planners and
policy makers
Kristina's initiatives embody the ideals
of a humanistic education and engaged
citizenship and she has inspired us to
appreciate architecture as a powerful
artistic act that can help shape a
better world for her past
accomplishments and her future promise
Yale College is honored to award the
Lewis of the prize for excellence in the
creative arts to Christina
[Applause]
the alkis henry snow prize is awarded to
that senior who through the combination
of intellectual achievement character
and personality shall be adjudged by the
faculty who have done the most forgive
by inspiring his or her classmates in
admiration and love for the best
traditions of high scholarship this year
the snow prize is awarded to Richard
Thomas McCoy
[Applause]
described as a once-in-a-generation
talent Tom McCoy has a truly outstanding
record at Yale elected the Phi Beta
Kappa in his junior year and winner last
fall the heart Lyman prize awarded to
the most distinguished member of the
junior class Tom graduates summa [ __ ]
laude with distinction in the logistics
major having earned a 4.0 GPA and
straight A's and all of the 36.5 credits
his studies demonstrate the breadth and
depth of his intellectual interests both
in linguistics and in a range of other
subjects from computer science and
mathematics to Old Norse literature and
mythology next year he goes on to pursue
a PhD at Johns Hopkins University in
cognitive science at Yale tom has been
tireless in his education to teaching
and mentoring middle and high school
students in New Haven his professors
admired him for his work as an organizer
and teacher for the North American
computational linguistics Olympiad which
he introduced to Yale's Department of
linguistics and they note the impact he
has had on students at underperforming
New Haven public schools as well as on
our own students and faculty for his
outstanding academic achievements his
love of learning and a desire to share
it with students of all ages Yale
College takes great pleasure in
bestowing the Alphaeus Henry snow prize
upon Richard Thomas
[Applause]
hi everybody
I'm very nervous great um so I just have
a couple things to save Dean Halloween
and I need your guys's help um so it's
me a little bit of calm response since
our talk with so um when I say um when I
say away can you say stay you guys
you're that Hardy
alright so with practice away away
that's great okay cool um all right so
now I'm gonna mess a a while can you say
kind of quickly
you're really swell guy okay a while a
while okay cool
ah hey sounds Lancer okay ready
[Music]
by the way don't go away Holloway a
while is old go away
how I say I remember meeting you I love
the dr. J you still keep track of me but
I said it was ok we talked about
Saliva's mustache you ghost you look so
dapper in fifty books talk about
fellowships friendships and rocket ships
set sail from Yale on your deanship to
trouble Slams
[Music]
so we say a while I don't know we say a
while but in this we've got a
replacement who has tons of fun and
teacher psych 101 was actually so please
welcome to demolish I
[Applause]
[Laughter]
very impressed by the job he does so now
we sing if you have to go away really
good really good all right
[Applause]
Dean Holloway and Steve administrators
and faculty friends and family and the
members of the class of 2017 welcome I'm
so sorry to interrupt
um really quickly has anyone seen a
water bottle um do you have to do that
I'm sorry I did you I'm already very
parched um just sort of right off the
bat um if anyone would look after okay
you're right it's totally fine okay I'll
find you later you're doing amazing
go go go go go go go go Dean hallway
esteemed administrators and faculty
friends and family and members of the
class of 2017 welcome thank you guys so
much
it's agreed that we're all here fifty
thousand us are here at the same time
thank you guys so much for filling out
the doable we are so honored to be
speaking here today and sharing the same
stage as Theo Epstein who and Jordan
correct me if I'm wrong invented the
bazooka that is much no no okay yes he
led the cops to the shores grocery
victory okay he he's the president of
the Chicago Cubs
he's big mr. baseball okay yes big mr.
baseball cata anyway we wanted to start
the speech by thanking all the amazing
individuals who have helped make you the
place that is um well first of course
presidents holiday I'm looking sure but
it's kind of funny you know we started
our four years I started out for four
years here with him and we're moving on
now and he's still here because
bluegrass is not a writing credit where
is he whoo that's is not writing Fred
which wound up petition would not go
through there's handsome Dan that would
yeah that adorable pup who we all dream
of one day punting
[Applause]
[Applause]
no one wants to pop handsome Dan charlie
okay well then why are you so small
right think about it alright okay uh d
hallway who in addition to being such an
amazing Dean Riggs final cut year after
year no one's talking about it guys no
one's talking about it okay that's why
he's leaving we know and there of course
the many staff members here who make
life possible and whose work often goes
and unacknowledged um in the immortal
words of Linda the nature of the save a
dying
[Applause]
we want a way to lean down to make sure
to save your dining hall oh you know
Jordan we know oh you're the one
stealing all the Captain Crunch
if you ready that bad yeah you could
just ask us inspire we wanted to thank
we wanted to thank the Yale corporation
as well although might I add that the
Yale corporation Kuppa a worker too
controversial yeah
none of the investment portfolio suckers
are going in this way no lady okay yeah
that the Yale corporation is great
[Applause]
no complaints here great corporation
just the best
10 out of 10 um and we couldn't finish
these things about of course sasha pop
tees whiteford beautiful bundle of joy
are you serious okay oh my god no no
okay it's not that it's not that it's
just I don't know okay one time I was at
a party with her sophomore year and we
didn't really know each other that well
and it was very like we were casually
talking and I mentioned offhand I was
like oh I'm thinking of applying to
global affairs and she just goes oh I
don't think you'll get in oh yeah right
looks so weird
so we sober true like oh she's so next
no she was she not to me anyway last but
not least we have to thank our
classmates it is such an honor to be
here with you guys today I mean just to
know that we've been studying and
partying with people who in just a few
short years will be doing incredible
things like defrauding a middle-class
we're making headlines for being on
trial for defrauding the middle class
[Applause]
carry you
[Applause]
you guys inspire us every single day I
mean just consider all the amazing work
our classmates will be doing and filled
as diverse as wealth management and
identity management and hedge fund
management and management consulting and
fire consulting and I don't know things
as quirky as investment making it's
incredible to know that this class is
ready to make the world a better place
but but this is about all of us and we
wanted to take some time to recognize
some of the amazing things we've
accomplished together as a class but
first of all we were part of a pivotal
moment in Gale and national history
while we were here you'll see this roll
up to demand a much needed change in the
culture of this institution it was fall
2015 we have the unit mobilized to
accomplish something that no one ever
thought we would we became a
tobacco-free campus
[Applause]
I'm sorry Ellen is everybody going to do
that intimately but you should be more
smoke on campus and obviously less of it
then there is before but seriously guys
Cheers the guys through all that it
happens we learn that it is one thing to
receive the embedded racism of an
institution like you but to claim that
our administrators should be paid for an
acting out racism unacceptable
unacceptable unacceptable yeah okay many
inside and outside of Yale criticize the
student protest as being impingements on
free speech which was confusing to us at
first because we thought protesting was
exercising or free speech but yeah but
then we realized you know you are
allowed to critique racism
you just can't yell about us keep it
down keep it down there libraries around
right I love you turn around people are
trying to study yes
keep it down um uh what you know the
racism may still be here but we'll just
focus focus
and you can smell right yeah my borscht
my boys are clear yeah you know but
through tribulation there is knowledge
and that above all is what gal has given
us I mean we have learned so much are
you Muller for example that Theo Epstein
invented a bazooka Noah that should be
gone that is wrong yeah um we hope we
learn that we look at is not about how
accomplished you are or who or who you
know or how you dress or who your family
is already with the high school is what
all those things
[Applause]
all the same time yeah every day it
never ends
possibly we learn that despite our
juvenile college rivalries all of the
residential colleges are spoiler alert
basically the same except for Trumbull
which is objectively worse
sorry we just did the math I don't know
sorry
and that's a mess before all the amazing
things you learn in class guys yeah oh
my god like for example I took chemistry
of food and cooking credit D and I
learned that baking soda is just a fancy
word for salt they did not tell you that
well I got a C and that's passing so
Kathy credit look it is a scary world we
are about to be entering institutions
are crumbling all around us America is
succumbing to fascism the planet is in
the throes of climate crisis and we're
turning 23 next year it is crazy
Oh weird I think so old
take a quarter century after melting um
so before we go guys uh luckily be not
with the answers both of the questions
that we hope will guide you through this
next phase of life
now regimen yeah questions like what
does it mean to be responsible given the
immense privilege and power of a Yale
degree how do I live a life full of
meaning and love why won't they let me
punch handsome there but in a way you
know members of class 2017 who she had
the answers for you you know but in a
way we have something even better
everybody look under your seats can
anybody find a waterbomb are very
personally I'm very thirsty
[Applause]
[Music]
class of 2017 today we gather here on
old campus as many galas have done
before us to celebrate traditions that
stretch back as far as 200 years when
classmate was once known as presentation
day as your classmate Cheers
Larry and I like to share today's
traditions with you seniors if you
actually look underneath your chairs now
you will find a clay churchwarden pipe a
tradition that was first recorded by a
member of the class of 1869 for the last
150 years on class a seniors have
brought these pipes outside formed a
circle of friends and shared one last
smoke together and don't worry we know
what you're thinking the pipe is great
for blowing bubbles so we've included
some bubble solution in the bag
beginning in 1851 graduating classes
have also planted a sprig of I read
somewhere on campus symbolic of enduring
nature other friendships made at Yale
this year's ivy was planted at the front
of false gate and sits directly below
the stone that bears our class year both
the ID and the stone will be reminded to
those entering and leaving campus of the
class of 2017 this year we are also
excited to continue a more recent
tradition started in 2011 seniors each
of you have been given the class
anthology a short collection of works
written by our peers the booklet
contains the ODEs and speeches given
here today in addition to the
submissions of the finalists in future
years refer back to this anthology to
reflect on our time here at Yale and a
new aided and before today
our alma mater we will be a twist on an
old tradition since 2007 the class
history has been delivered as a short
film rather than a series of speeches
written produced and directed by our
peers a copy of the short film will be
preserved in the collections of the
binary library and perhaps more
permanently on YouTube no matter how
these traditions change over time the
spirit of class day has truly remained
the same
today repeated homage to the rich
traditions that characterized this
exciting time in our lives we hope that
you enjoy these traditions and that in
some way they strengthen the ties
between friends that have made this
place our home so without further ado we
leave you with the audio
[Applause]
I once read that the shortest distance
between two people is a story this one
has been for years in the making
the story begins with you marveling at
your dumb luck or it begins with
self-sacrifice a balancing act on the
backs of those whose art spies and
sweats fueled your ambition or maybe it
begins with your mothers calluses a
hardness that wrapped itself around you
hole held you like a precious dream or a
pair of eyes that look upon you with
unwavering belief or maybe even the
story begins for some of you more than
you'll like to admit with a sinking
sensation the creep of a shadow
whispering with arrogant certainty that
you must be that one mistake years of
unlearning and relearning what it means
to feel apart and yet part and parcel of
something inconceivably bigger here you
are not an admissions mistake but the
best damn decision they have ever made
if the shortest distance between two
people really is a single story how many
have you told to close the gap between
you and the person sitting right next to
you today stories that came pouring out
over late-night egg and cheese
sandwiches and those that you
reluctantly revealed when it was simply
too late to care about the problems that
do that
this morning how many cups of coffee and
bath cubicles and sunrises shared after
yet another all-nighter and $5 boxes of
Popeyes and episodes on Netflix with
said box of Popeyes and hours spent at
study breaks when they could have been
spent studying and dark nights that grew
dimmer with crippling self-doubt and
soft smiles from strangers who morphed
into family just as quickly as the
leaves in this city change color how
many failures and falls that your body
bear and bear witness to how many hands
did it take to put everything back
together how much honest laughter filled
the empty spaces in the less than
perfect assembly of pieces you call
yourself how many how much how often did
you walk down college or Elm or Chapel
Street surrounded by a particular
history maybe yours maybe one that could
not even conceive of you at a place like
this how many times did you walk look up
and think here I am home home like your
freshman suite making furniture out of
cardboard because the struggle was just
too real home like the fists and voices
that rose up high to remind you that yes
your life matters home like the one you
build an anchor right between you and
another stranger Sol with a story the
plot does not end today there is still
so much distance to shorten to many
blank pages to scratch ourselves
unapologetically onto with so much love
to give and the unyielding belief that
we really don't know until we get there
that we are okay that we are more than
okay
that we have a story to tell
[Applause]
hi hello everyone we are the
co-directors and producers at this
year's class day video all of the
footage you are about to see and all the
spoken word and music you are about to
hear was shot written and recorded by
members of the class of 2017 we are
returning to tradition with this year's
video - something that resembles the old
class history speeches and it's non
fictional and inclusive spirit this year
we are proud to present a documentary
short that takes you on a journey
through a theatre theoretical day in the
life of class upon 17
without further ado sit back relax and
enjoy today's feature presentation class
of 2017
we dedicate this video to you
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my freshman year was actually losing
stuff about my crew and my broker was
out there she's all she's like oh my god
you're Nick
so I went on foot right there like my
move on with my life dirty t-shirt my
life like basketball tan and my life
self that had been preparing for hiking
my life not showering for a few days and
then I realized everyone else is wearing
really nice glove and that's like their
whole freshman I was embarrassed I think
surprised me because when it was very
confident scientists as well as a bit of
like fine art I was thinking about this
because I remember freshman year I
wanted more like you so much that I sat
and listened to someone talking about
like their family like drama the same
story like five times it was so long and
I was like okay with that
and now I would say
well I joined the yo woman's varsity
crew
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
in the inaugural class of the Russian
Scholars Program we voted a special yeah
yeah super excited to Bofors first woman
president so she's my first stop here
this was like the most extreme formal go
- shotgun ever experienced in my life
so I think one of many things that Gail
has done for me as a person is it as I
expanded my my outlook on life on cable
and show me just how many things I
didn't know I didn't even know
[Applause]
[Music]
my favorite kind of consistent memory is
tap night I remember there were 11 of us
our first year and they had very all
black and has linked up that goose in
the middle of old campus nicely packed
shampoo and I found chargers and I ever
said being swept away at Cape Cod but we
did leave in a bird unfortunateiy my
favorite memory oh I think I'll yield is
out celebrating my birthday with them in
my house one day when I brought them
over to tour with me in Miami and in
Tampa and when they sang to my old
professors at my old college I remember
in software here when we had the one
snow day that we ever had at Yale and we
stayed up really late and I'd ran around
in the snow in the street like rationing
absurd yeah I'd rather brash it out you
know like characters and chips I never
liked freshman boys like hoarding chips
yeah there they don't survive post
apocalyptic vision of what what happened
to Yale is society collapsed last year
definitely six out there's always
incredible crowd for that and obviously
to the rest of the community Harbor good
man
[Applause]
I advise 57 in a squid because
everybody's that and turcica what I
can't afford this be 49 okay I guess
it's a fee the rice crispies
and they're still over it all I can't
leave
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you have gone through all kinds of
journeys to get where you are now you're
about to head out on all kinds of other
Germans my wish for you then that the
matter here in the future in every
journey you always have friends
here's your friends I will miss having
space to do theater and to do
performance which has been my entire
observing their lives I also sing enough
color group mom and happen crawling on
college yeah just yeah Peninsula the
closeness
one of the conversations prefer
[Music]
11 p.m. blue state conversations of some
of the most valuable learning
experiences of ever definitely
functional for sure
Sophie both in a year when you're kind
of in a time crunch we would jet music
online eat pizza in the garage work on
the car Nissan parts good memories and
friendships I did Street actually at
this particular that's all good culture
throwing is something that you will see
crew do all your four years if you
choose to stick with it I think that's a
really special thing if I'm struggling
in my future life I'll remember how
difficult my experience has been for the
routine and I'll know that because I
stuck with it I think
really sick room and
honestly I'm sad but I'm sad to leave
but
back in college back on he's not raised
eyes with these guys
Yoda sing a poem this is hip-hop just
want you to know so stay right and stick
tight to the flow but this is more than
just a lesson in the field of black
expression in fact it's more a
reflection of the time that's been
invested let me take y'all back to when
I was brimming with excitement didn't
really sleep though technically I close
my eyelids I really yanked the silence
since July when I got placed in Berkeley
College objectively the best option so
it's my first day at Yale and finally
something through the gates I'm giddy
with excitement goofy look upon my face
bunk bed is in a closet bookshelf in no
space Blue Book is in my pocket too new
suite mates and I got myself to make but
where do I go I got a thousand
opportunities but how do I grow I think
I'm catching on slow they're saying it
all like mo they like you lucky I know
but there's still more to the show I
mean just look at the history this is
the place of Presidents princesses and
the most elite honestly this place it
wasn't built for me but now I see this
is our Yale community and it's brimming
with diversity and unity the saint of
school this is hip-hop remix in it all
to bring order to the chaos and all of
us being rhythm we here to treat the
cause and not the symptom a better world
is the only mission and now we're
rapping at the table from women and
lyrical homage to those so long
unadmitted
when I look back and see a better path
call for future children and I
appreciate every one of y'all who
stopped to listen cuz this is bigger
than all of us here today it's bigger
than Grace Hopper Polly Maria Boucher we
remix in the world that all of us can be
a part of we out here we been here we
ain't leavin and we all love
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I leave here eventually but before we
evacuate let's have a good time also the
motto Chipotle congratulations
Yale classes 2007 change I have one very
hardy word freedom come visit factor 17
[Applause]
congratulations class of 2017 in wave
travels in the Academy over the last 20
or 30 years I've come to learn one thing
that Yale students are the kindest and
most persevering students I've ever
encountered hi I'm Ken Burns
congratulations to the Yale class of
2017 my voice is pretty simple know
yourself persevere and now in these
difficult times engage congratulations
class of 2017 never stop humbly
discerning and bravely pursuing all that
truly makes life worth living
congratulations you did it you're
graduating we're so proud of you
good luck it's sort of what makes work
with you I'd especially like to
acknowledge
congratulate those of you that endure
the dreaded biology when I shoot
foundations I wish you the best and I
hope that you would continue to share
your passions with others
congratulations class of 2017 your wall
written congratulations to the class of
2017 and special shout-out to the
physicists I do have one piece of advice
and that is to always do your best and
when your best happens to be just
staring out the window that's all you
can muster to be gentle with yourself
congratulations Yale class of 2017 so
child do you have any advice for the
class of 2017 congratulations class of
2017 we wish all the best
congratulations class of 2017 I'm so
grateful for my bright college years I'm
so grateful for the bright years to come
I am so grateful to Newhaven
my beautiful hometown thank you for
raising me thank you for raising this
clear institution that has given me
these people thank you to the professors
who have given me the confidence to seek
my voice thank you to the professors who
have danced on the grave of my ego they
use all of Yale staff for making this
place possible thank you for loving and
challenging me thank you to the people
who have yet to change my life I'm so
excited to meet you to show you these
stars I made room for in my sky Yale
thank you for opening my horizon class
of 2017 I do not know what the future
holds thank you for walking with me into
this darkness uncertain overwhelming we
will find our way by each other's
flickering light thank you thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Berger college
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in you marry much every rested day
[Applause]
you
you